venezuela's president nicholas maduro
and iran's president ibrahim raci meet
in tehran and agree on a 20-year
cooperation deal
with this government cooperation has
taken place in the fields of energy
economy science agriculture and defense
the signing of this agreement is another
step in expanding relations in the
coming years
venezuela's close ties with iran date
back to its former president hugo chavez
but under maduro the two opec members
have become closer since both were
sanctioned by the united states
we will be witnesses in the coming years
how our countries will confront the
difficulties they face and create a new
world the youth in venezuela the youth
in iran must know that the world of the
future will be a just world without
imperialism
iran already supplies venezuela with
crude oil and provides technical support
to its oil industry but analysts say
maduro's trip is also about solidarity
i do think that it is significant that
the two countries are trying to join up
against american pressure
and we have to remember that they're not
alone we also have countries such as
russia and china at the same time
however we have to remember that all of
these four countries they have different
grievances when it comes to the
americans
maduro's trip to iran coincides with the
summit of the americas that's taking
place in los angeles washington didn't
invite him to the high-level meeting
speaking at the summit u.s secretary of
state anthony blinken said venezuela's
president should resume talks with the
country's opposition
in our judgment venezuelan-led
negotiations um between the maduro
regime and the unitary platform
are the best path that we can see
to trying to restore to venezuelans um a
democracy that they clearly deserve and
clearly want
it's a call that's almost certain to be
ignored instead iran and venezuela
united against a common enemy appear
closer than ever victoria gatenbee al
jazeera